after his day in court Donald Trump was
back in New Jersey
[Applause]
back at his golf course surrounded by
his supporters his fundraisers his
faithful
[Applause]
and it was clear his Central defense is
attack
today we win
will and heinous abuse of power in the
history of our country
this day will go down and infamy and Joe
Biden will forever be remembered as not
only the most corrupt president of the
history of our country but perhaps even
more importantly
the president who together with a band
of his closest thugs Misfits and
marxists tried to destroy American
democracy
his day had begun hours earlier far to
the south in Miami
so here to the question which had
brought Donald Trump to court and this
remarkable moment in U.S history
president
great he said and then into the armored
car for the Convoy to court
as every second of this was captured he
was on his own social media site Witch
Hunt he posted
at court the crowd the crowd swelled for
a spectacle that we wouldn't see
away from the cameras on the 13th floor
in court number three president Trump
along with his aide Walt router
surrendered themselves to the duty
magistrate they were under arrest on
federal charges
if the aim is to pit the people against
the institutions that are supposed to
hold the country together well then his
National support base is certainly
strong enough to deepen the division
trying to get these mental shackles off
of us by waking the people up and
sometimes I guess things have to be a
little bit dramatic and they have to be
a little bit extreme for people's eyes
to open they can try all the tricks they
want in the book it's not going to work
we still support him no matter what
Edith is in jail what happens next is
our Biden Goes to Jail Trump becomes
president he pardons himself and we're
gonna whoop their ass
well he was in the courthouse for almost
exactly an hour he sat stone-faced and
it was left for his lawyer to say we
most certainly plead not guilty then as
the Convoy left this
foreign
he was an anti-trump protester
he was quickly arrested it was just a
moment of tension in a day that was
otherwise peaceful
and then the spectacle moved on to the
city's most famous Cuban Cafe a photo op
and birthday wishes for a man who turns
77 today
[Applause]
[Music]
the birthday celebrations continued back
in New Jersey
nice birthday where there was also a
hint of what his defense in court might
look like many people have asked me why
I had these boxes why did you want them
the answer in addition to having every
right under the presidential records Act
is that these boxes were
containing all types of personal
belongings many many things shirts and
shoes and everything his legal team will
Mount that defense in federal court he
will present it to the court of public
opinion over and over in rallies across
the country Mark Stone Sky News in Miami